Is HBO's "The Last of Us" the first really
good video game adaptation? Time will tell,
but early reviews are uniformly positive.
Tension and "The Last of Us" have gone
hand-in-sweaty-controller-holding hand since
the original video game masterpiece was released
in 2013. The post-apocalyptic tale of Joel and
Ellie's fungus-riddled road trip is one of the
greats and earned the right to be in the same
conversation as "The Walking Dead" and "Mad Max"
as far as stories set at the end of the world go.
That stress level has been raised
again in the past few weeks in the
lead-up to HBO's live-action adaptation
— arriving on January 15 — handled by
the game's creator, Neil Druckmann,
and "Chernobyl" creator Craig Mazin.
Fans have been waiting with great
anticipation to see just how Pedro
Pascal and Bella Ramsey have handled playing
two icons of not just video games but one of
the greatest survival horror stories ever
told. Well, now the wait is finally over.
Critics have shuffled in online like
Clickers with their final verdicts on
the all-new series ahead of its release
this Sunday. Has the unthinkable finally
happened? Has "The Last of Us" been
given the treatment it deserves in its
transition to live action? By the sounds
of things, it may have even surpassed it,
as the show is sitting at 100% on Rotten
Tomatoes, as of the making of this video.
Empire gave it a perfect score of 5/5,
praising it for accomplishing where
others failed. John Nugent wrote,
In the game, Ashley Johnson and Troy
Baker are the performers beneath the
pixels of Ellie and Joel. Bella Ramsey and
Pedro Pascal are our live-action iterations
of the young girl with a big secret and
the father figure forced to protect her.
"I'm not family?"
"No. You're cargo."
Admittedly, Pascal playing the reluctant guardian
of a youngster isn't anything new for him given
the fact he's been doing it off-world for some
time now as Din Djarin in "The Mandalorian". The
real success story, however, looks to be coming
from Ramsey, whose role on "The Last of Us" will
undoubtedly demand more of the young star as
the show progresses. Simon Cardy of IGN wrote,
It turns out, though, that while these might
be winning turns from the show's leads,
there's a surprise in the supporting cast
that might steal the show from them.
Minor spoilers for Episode 3 ahead.
As much as Joel and Ellie will try to avoid
strangers and infected stragglers during their
journey, "The Last of Us" the game does include
some supporting stars who are willing to help,
albeit reluctantly. One fine example is Bill,
the antisocial ally played on the show by Nick
Offerman, who shares the screen with his
on-screen love, Frank, played by Murray
Bartlett of "The White Lotus." According to
Daniel Fienberg of the Hollywood Reporter,
Something that's only briefly hinted
at in the game, Bill and Frank's time
together is seemingly brought
to the forefront in the show.
If it does yield a nomination or two come
awards season, by the sounds of things,
it wouldn't be the only one for "The
Last of Us." One of the best games
ever made might have just become
one of the best shows of 2023.